Seit wochen tobt ein heftiger sandsturm auf dem mars wurde heftigste seit dem menschen den mars beobachten und er hört einfach nicht auf anfang juni
entwickelte er sich wuchs enorm an und umspannt mittlerweile den kompletten planeten mit heftigen konsequenzen
herzlich willkommen bei klick zum science fiction
Mitte juni gab es die ersten konsequenzen die nasa musste mitteilen dass der kontakt zu ihrem rover opportunity
abgebrochen ist ein absolutes drama der mars rover curiosity
dagegen hat wohl noch energie und zwar aufgrund seiner radionuklid batterie
forschungsteams nutzen jetzt alle möglichkeiten um das heftige wetterphänomen genauer zu untersuchen
ja und wie man sich so einen staubsturm auf dem mars vorstellen kann und
ob opportunity wiederbeleben kann das sind die fragen ja quasi jedes jahr gibt es
staubstürme auf dem mars teilweise sind sie groß wie ganze kontinente auf der erde doch der aktuelle sturm ist besonders denn mittlerweile
umkreis der den ganzen planeten solche maß staubstürme können plötzlich auftauchen und
monatelang andauern bei dem aktuellen sturm scheint es sich um mehrere kleine aktive stürme zu handeln die sich
zusammengeschlossen haben wahrscheinlich ausgelöst durch einen einzelnen lokalen sturm der ende mai
beobachtet werden konnte ende juni deklarierte die nasa das wetterphänomen als
planeten umfassendes staub ereignis schon zu diesem zeitpunkt waren 41 millionen
quadratkilometer betroffen mehr als russland und
nordamerika zusammen und das hat folgen für die nasa und ihre rover auf dem mars der feine staub bedeckt ihre paneele und
stört die elektronik anders als im film der marsianer aber ist der sturm war lange nicht so wuchtig wie dort dargestellt
das liegt an der dünnen atmosphäre doch es gibt eben trotzdem negative folgen denn der sturm blockierter sonnenlicht und der rover opportunity
bekommt jetzt keine sonne mehr ab die seine solarzellen für energiegewinnung nutzen können opportunity
hat jedenfalls seit mitte juni keinen kontakt mehr zur nasa er hat sich wohl
weitestgehend
abgeschaltet dies passiert wenn die akkuladung soweit feld das sich der rover
selbstständig in einen ruhemodus
versetzen dann ist nur noch seine uhr aktiviert die ihnen dann nach einiger zeit auch wieder wecken könnte bis dahin sollte opportunity wieder etwa
sonnenlicht gesehen haben und seine akkus mit energie aufgeladen haben dazu ein
projektmanager der nasa john callas wir machen uns sorgen aber wir hoffen dass der sturm aufhört und der rover mit uns kommunizieren
wird man könne durchaus noch optimistisch sein denn seine batterien hätten insgesamt noch 85
ihrer ursprünglichen kapazität behalten und das trotz der bereits mehr als
5000 lade und entladezyklen
es handelt sich schließlich um die besten batterien im sonnensystem glück im unglück haben auch weil der sturm jetzt im sommer auftreten
die nachttemperaturen sind dann vergleichsweise mild nacht sind es um die minus 33 grad celsius dem rover
könnte ohne den betrieb seiner batterie dennoch im schlimmsten fall dasselbe schicksal drohen wie dem rover spirit der
2010 wohl auf dem mars
eingefroren ist opportunity
selbst ist schon seit ende januar 2004 auf dem roten planeten unterwegs und hat die ziele seiner entwickler damit längst übertroffen
ursprünglich war geplant dass er 90 tage lang den planeten erkunden soll
mittlerweile hat er in den 14 jahren schon rund 45 kilometer zurückgelegt der mars rover curiosity
dagegen verfügt wohl trotz des sturms weiter über energie das liegt an seiner
radionuklid batterie ich hatte erwähnt die ihn unabhängig von sonnenlicht macht bei all den negativnachrichten sie die nasa in dem gigantischen
sandsturm aber auch eine chance
forschungsteams wollen endlich mehr über dieses wetterphänomen auf dem roten planeten
erfahren warum zb treten sie in einigen jahren auch in anderen aber nicht warum sind sie manchmal so
gigantisch und manchmal so klein wann und warum weitet sich ein regionaler sturm zu einem globalen phänomen aus
antworten auf diese fragen könnten dabei helfen
mehr über das klima des mars aber auch über seine vergangenheit und vor allem über seine zukunft zu erfahren denn für
zukünftige mars mission deren pläne ja immer konkreter werden wäre es sehr wichtig zu wissen
in welchen dimensionen mit solchen stürmen zu rechnen ist genau dazu ist jetzt
eine absolut optimale gelegenheit seit dem letzten großen sturm im jahr 2007 hatten planeten forscher und forscherinnen förmlich darauf gewartet
denn langfristig gesehen plant man die entwicklung von modellen die als werkzeug dienen könnten um solche staubstürme
vorherzusagen also vergleichbar mit den vorhersagen von
hurricanes und so weiter auf der erde doch dafür ist erst einmal eine ansammlung großer datenmengen
mengen eine wichtige voraussetzung drei auge sondern könnten das übernehmen zum einen der mars reconnaissance orbiter
lro der ähnliche wetterdaten und bilder wie irdischem etwa satelliten liefern kann zudem auch die sonde maven die die obere atmosphäre
während des sturms beobachtet und zudem auch die sonde mars odyssey
die über eine infrarot kamera verfügt und somit die dichte und beschaffenheit des staubes
analysieren erst in diesen tagen hat die nasa jedenfalls klargemacht dass der staubsturm weitere missionen in der zukunft nicht verhindern wird man habe in den
letzten beiden wochen beobachten können dass der sturm seinen höhepunkt erreicht habe und sich die massive staubmenge in der atmosphäre langsam beruhigen wird ende november
soll ja der insight länder auf der marsoberfläche
abgesetzt werden man gehe fest davon aus dass der aktuelle stimmung dann
abgeflaut seid doch selbst dann gehe man von einer abstaubt nebel aus der dann weiter in der marsatmosphäre
hängt der macher nicht nur die landung selbst zu einer herausforderung sondern könnte dann ebenfalls
den einsatz der technischen geräte behindern wenn er keine videos dazu wir werden natürlich
über die folgen berichten und über die landung und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann hättet mich bei whatsapp
darum geht die kaputte abo boxer auf youtube und verpasst kein video
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir von allen videos und zwar noch bevor es die leute hier auf youtube
erfahren und zwar täglich und garantiert einfach hier draufklicken und am besten auch mein schwesterkanal
klicks um social media abonnieren da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt dafür hier klicken aber nicht die
bürger vergessen und hier geht es weiter damit du dafür auch draufklicken
sensationsfund auf dem mars der ist wirklich sensationell bis dann
bleib dran